PROFESSOR: E less than v0.
So you have an incident
wave, e to the ikx, incident,
and a reflected wave that you
have, e to the minus ikx--
remember minus the other face--
and e to the 2i delta of E.
So this is the incident wave,
and this is the reflected wave.
They correspond to
your Ae to the ikx
plus Be to the minus ikx.
Remember, when the
energy was less than v0,
the range of B over A was
minus e to the 2i delta.
And since I take A equals
1, you get this thing.
So suppose I construct a psi
incident of x less than 0
and t as the sum 0 to infinity
dk f of k e to the ikx
e to the minus iEt over h bar.
Whew.
So I superimpose the
incident thing here.
Then the reflected one
should be superimposed too
and would be 0 to
infinity, a minus in front
because there's a minus, dk
f of k e to the minus ikx
e to the 2i delta of E e to
the minus iEt over h bar.
Whew.
That's the reflected
wave superimposed.
So now you've
constructed everything.
Here the reflected wave
is more interesting
than the transmitted
wave, because there's
no real big transmitted wave.
It just whistles out.
But the reflective
thing is interesting.
If you're doing the experiment,
you send in a particle,
you want to see
what you get back.
That's going to tell you
what kind of potential
you can expect it encountered.
So let's do the stationary
phase for this one,
for the reflected.
Let's see how it moves.
We know how the incident moves.
The incident moves
with x equals--
we've done it
there-- hk0 over m t.
But how about this one?
Well, this one you would
have to do d dk of minus kx
plus 2 delta of E minus Et over
h bar, all that at k0 equals 0.
And you'll probably
remember that this thing
was in your midterm
and your first test.
You had this wave, and
you had to analyze,
what did stationary phase do?
And it does that.
So what do you get?
Well, when you take
the derivative,
you have to take the derivative
of delta with respect
to energy, that's delta prime,
and then derivative of energy
with respect to t.
Let me save you a little time.
The answer is minus h bar
k0 m t minus 2h bar delta
prime of E. OK.
That's what you get.
That's how this packet moves.
And what does it do really?
Remember, this is defined
for x less than 0.
So this is valid--
forget about this
little term here--
this is valid for t positive.
For t positive, you're going
to get this to satisfy.
So this is a big wave
packet for t positive.
It's the reflected wave.
That's what you would expect.
This is the reflected.
Now, if this factor
was not here,
it is as if, well, the incoming
packet hit the origin at t
equals 0.
And this will be perfect
bouncing in which
the packet gets reflected.
And at t equals 0, it
starts to move to the left.
And as t increases, it's moved
more and more to the left.
You see it there, because
x must be negative.
But if there is
this term, it really
doesn't start to
move to the left
until t is bigger than
that so that x is negative.
So only at t equal to
this amount of time
the packet reflects.
So there's a delay,
and the delay
is 2h bar delta prime of E.
So this is a
technology people use
in scattering theory to figure
out what kind of potential
you have, figure out
how much things get
delayed from the bouncing.
Now, this derivative-- we've
plotted it there-- delta
prime of E. You get a
big delay for low energy,
for energies near v0, and in
the middle it's not so big.